We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. now
I do not give financial advice to others on
the program, but I am going to, after listening
to this voicemail, I am going to have to give
us some general advice.
Let's take a listen to it.
Hey David, this is Spencer from Ohio.
Um, I'm paying a pretty high portion, uh,
of my wage to student loans, trying to get
rid of them as soon as possible, but with
Bernie Sanders, uh, likely becoming president,
uh, next year.
Uh, when do you think I should just stop paying
my student loans?
Uh, thank you.
Bye.
Yeah, so I don't give personalized financial
advice on this program and this is not personalized.
This is a general thing.
I would not stop paying my student loans.
If I were you on the assumption that Bernie
will be president and Bernie will cancel all
of your student loan debt.
Okay.
First of all, there's a question as to whether
Bernie will be the next president.
Will Bernie be the next nominee?
We've got to get past that hurdle.
If Bernie is the nominee, will he win the
2020 election?
Got to get past that hurdle.
Then Bernie would not be inaugurated for nearly
another year, 11 months.
I guess.
How quickly could he cancel student loan debt?
It could be awhile.
We don't know so would even succeed at doing
it.
So my general advice to people is don't start
getting into arrears on student loan debt,
on the idea that Bernie is going to be president
and cancel the student loan debt.
Now if you have mechanisms, if you are paying
extra towards the student loans and that's
financially taxing you, you could evaluate
your financial situation, see if it makes
sense to pay the minimum, which would of course
over time leads you to pay more interest but
maybe it would give you a more viable financial
position in the immediate.
If you, depending on the loans you have and
your employment situation, you can ask for
loan.
A temporary suspension, is it called forbearance
where you can suspend making payments but
you've got to go through that process.
I would not advise anyone in the audience
to say, here's an idea.
I'm not going to pay my student loans anymore.
I think that that is a very, very bad idea.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about gun girl.
We've talked about this gun rights activist,
Kaitlin Bennett, who was just swarmed by student
protesters at Ohio university.
We will also talk about some rural conservative
Oregonians who are interested in switching
States and becoming part of Idaho in rural,
rural Oregon.
And then we are going to talk about lawsuits
for nonpayment of medical expenses, all of
those stories and much more on today's bonus
show tonight.
Democrats debate.
Will it be Bernie versus Minnie?
Mike?
Just kidding.
Will it be establishment versus Progressive's
or whatever?
Uh, join me tonight starting around 8:15 PM
Eastern time on YouTube,
which for a debate pre-show, we will then
have debate analysis and post show.
Hope to see you there.
And on today's bones, show the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].